from our leakage radiation our broadcast
television and radio you can tell some
amazing things about the planet and the
technological species that occupy it you
can certainly get the length of our day
you can get an estimate of the size of
the planet you can even deduce that we
don't have any kind of global governance
that's because in every region of the
planet television stations and radio
stations are assigned frequencies that
are specific to the different
International Telecommunications Union
regions around the globe and those
frequencies are similar but not exactly
the same so if you were getting the
broadcast transmission leakage from this
planet as our planet rotates and another
region comes into view on the horizon
you'd see that those transmission
frequencies shift a little and 24 hours
they're back to that same pattern and
you would probably deduce that the whole
planet was not operating as a single
geopolitical unit so we talked a little
about we and we often think about what's
gonna happen if we detect a signal and
certainly the SETI Institute is part of
a group of scientists who are working on
the project who've said well you know if
we detect a signal we're certainly going
to tell the world but we're not going to
transmit back until there's been some
global consensus that we should and then
you know we figure out who should speak
for Earth what should we say and that's
all great really hard to understand how
we'll do it and at the same time if you
announce that you've detected a signal
and you give the nature of the signal
you let other people know what you found
then it's human nature anyone who can
have access to some kind of a
transmitter is going to use it and
they're going to say whatever it is that
they want to say whatever we might want
to have in terms of this high-minded
intellectual response in Freeman Dyson
of his assistant Princeton at the
Institute for Advanced Studies premium
kind of chuckles every time we get into
this topic and he said you know think
about it that an orchestrated chaotic
cacophony that would emit from the
planet after the detection of a signal
he said wouldn't that be about the best
representation of 21st century earth
that you could imagine and I have to
agree that he's right nevertheless
scientists that we are we try and plan
for that and there's there's a a piece
of our website at the SETI Institute at
SETI org a project called Earth speaks
and one of our scientists is trying to
get people particularly young people to
tell us what message they'd like to send
if we were going to send a message to
another technological civilization and
what he's looking for our cultural
universals the kinds of ideas that come
from every society around the planet and
it's a way to try and see what at the
core it is to be human and what we'd
like the rest of the universe to know
about us
and